your doctor will perform surgical debridement
to remove
dead tissue in and around your
wound wounds can occur for a
variety of reasons such as injuries
expensive burns also called
pressure ulcers or
decubitus ulcers and infected surgical incisions
damaged or contaminated dead tissue
can compromise
circulation to the wound
plus diseased tissues are
prone to infection
dead tissues cause the
growth of bacteria that compete
with growth cells
for nutrients and interfere with the
healing process
healthy wound tissues can
becoming infected the infection can develop into a
pocket of pus called an abscess that
prevents wounds from healing a
wound from a burn
can form a hardened crust of
dead tissue called an escarce that can
prevent the growth of healthy tissue and faster
healing  your procedure your doctor will
numb the area around your
wound with a local anesthetic for
more extensive debridement you will receive
general anesthesia
to start your doctor may use
saline or disinfectant solutions to
wash or irrigate your wound
and then your doctor will assess the
depth of the wound  wound by checking the
extent of dead tissue
your doctor may remove the edge of the
tissues around the wound to
create a clean margin of healthy tissue
and improve healing
at the end of your procedure your doctor
will place a dry bandage on your wound
to  control any bleeding he
or she may also cover the wound
with moist gauze to promote
healing
after your procedure you will need to
follow the wound care instructions
very carefully be sure to
protect your wound from any knocks and
keep the wound and  clean, dry gauze pads